TIM ANDERSON: Hi and welcome
to Tech Tips From Teachers.
On this episode, we'll be
looking at mathematics apps.
Our guest today is
Melissa Kondrick
of Pleasanton, California.
Melissa teaches
middle school math,
holds a master's degree in
curriculum and instruction,
and sits on the technology
committee for her district.
Melissa, thanks so
much for joining us.
MELISSA KONDRICK:
Thanks for having me.
TIM ANDERSON: You've been
teaching for a couple of years
now.
During that time,
what sort of impact
have you seen technology have
on the way that students learn?
MELISSA KONDRICK:
Well the big buzz word
these days is Common Core.
And it's something about
these different standards that
aren't just preparing
students for the classroom,
but for everyday life.
And technology's one of
those big parts of it.
And you're going to
see in the future,
students aren't going
to have textbooks.
They're going to have
tablets and laptops
that they're going to be able
to get all their content with.
And so it's really
important for us
because now these standards
are more student-centric.
Students work with each
other and technology's
a way for them to be
able to work together,
which is really great.
TIM ANDERSON: Nice.
And then specifically
with math--
that's the subject that you
teach-- what sort of impact
have you seen technology
have on the delivery
and the consumption of those
specific math standards?
MELISSA KONDRICK: Technology
makes it so much easier,
especially for differentiation.
I have different students
that are on different parts
of their math journey.
Some are still a little
shaky on those fractions,
while others are ready to
move on to the next step.
And the technology
allows them to do
whatever they need at the pace
that they're comfortable with.
Also we can be able to scaffold
by having them get information
and feedback immediately,
versus before you would go home,
you'd come back, you
wouldn't know if you did it
right until the next day.
And technology helps be able
to get that information out
sooner.
TIM ANDERSON: We've synthesized
feedback for math teachers,
and have identified a few
key components for developers
to prioritize when
developing math apps.
It's important that these
apps have content that's
highly scaffolded, that they
have offline functionality,
and that the content is
mapped to the Common Core.
So you mentioned
differentiation earlier.
So why is scaffolded
content something
that's so crucial for
an app that's going
to be used in the classroom?
MELISSA KONDRICK: Well,
even though I only
teach sixth graders, they
need to know all the content
from the previous years.
And if students are able
to access that in one app
without being told,
that's really powerful.
Another thing too is that it
gives instant feedback, so
that when students are actually
doing the different games
and stuff in the app, they're
really learning old stuff,
but they're actually also
teaching themselves new stuff.
And let's be honest--
if you actually
get it from a talking
character besides a teacher,
you're more likely to be
willing to remember it.
So it gives students
a little bit more
of an independence
of their learning,
and they get to know what
they don't know and be
able to make that stronger.
TIM ANDERSON: Got it.
And then, with
offline functionality,
why is that something
that developers
should be keeping top of
mind when they're going
through and creating an app?
MELISSA KONDRICK: Well
we live in a digital age,
but not all of our buildings
and structures are at the area
that we need them to be.
So personally, our Wi-Fi
works about 80% of the time.
So 20% of the time,
I need a plan B.
And so having offline
capability is super important.
Another thing too is that it
limits distractions sometimes.
Because if students do have
access to the internet,
they're going to
go online and do
all the other things
besides the math
that they need to be doing.
And the other thing is if
they can get it anywhere,
anytime, they're
probably going to use it
more outside of school
than just in school
where they have Wi-Fi.
TIM ANDERSON: Got it.
Makes sense.
And then you mentioned
Common Core earlier.
So from a teacher
adoption standpoint,
why is it important that
this content is mapped back
to those Common Core standards?
MELISSA KONDRICK: We
take, us teachers,
a lot of time trying
to create pacing guides
and trying to find what's
important to actually be there
for our students.
We need something that's going
to be efficient and effective
in a short amount of time.
And so being able to be aligned
to the Common Core standards,
that right there gets me looking
at that app twice as much
as something that isn't.
And to be honest,
parents really want
to be able to know what
they can do at home as well.
And having at school
those standards at home,
it's really powerful for
parents to feel comfortable
helping their students
as much as they can.
TIM ANDERSON: Let's take
a look at some exemplar
apps for math-- Slice
Fractions, Desmos, and Matific.
Melissa, what makes
Slice Fractions
such a great app
for the classroom?
MELISSA KONDRICK: Oh my
gosh, it's so engaging.
Have you seen this?
There's this little mammoth,
and he's just cute as a button.
All I want to be able
to do is just find a way
to get him to the next step.
And it teaches students
whole and sliced fractions,
which is great.
It's highly
scaffolded, so students
can feel like they can try
the puzzle over and over again
and not have fear of failing.
Which means that they're
actually going to learn.
TIM ANDERSON: Nice.
And then what about Desmos?
What makes that something that's
a good fit for the classroom?
MELISSA KONDRICK: It's a
great powerful calculator,
and it has that offline
capability, where students
can be able to use it
anywhere and any time, which
is really great for
them-- in the classroom
when we don't have
Wi-Fi and also at home
if they don't have access.
TIM ANDERSON: Nice.
And then with Matific.
What makes that an app that's
important for other math
teachers to consider?
MELISSA KONDRICK: Well,
it's highly aligned
with the Common Core standards.
You can actually find
the standard and work
with it, which is really great.
It's developed by
early age math experts,
so it's coming from math people,
which is really important.
And it also goes with some
of the different curriculum
programs such as enVision Math,
Everyday Math, and Go Math,
which is actually a textbook
that we're currently using.
TIM ANDERSON: Very cool.
So something that
could be a huge time
saver for teachers,
which obviously
is going to affect adoption.
MELISSA KONDRICK:
Yeah and students
don't know they're
learning, because they're
playing a bunch of games.
TIM ANDERSON: So to recap, for
math apps in the classroom,
it's important the content
is highly scaffolded,
that the app has
offline functionality,
and the content is aligned
with the Common Core.
For more episodes of
Tech Tips from Teachers,
check out the Google
Developers channel on YouTube.
Thanks so much for
joining us today Melissa.
It's been great having you.
MELISSA KONDRICK:
It's been a blast.
Thanks for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]